the lions and tigers and you know what
the Bears um the right to bear arms I
can't help but recall that image every
time I think of a bear i see that um I
forget who had that maybe that person is
still here the right to bear arms a bear
sticking out his arms anyhow referencing
a previous stream and how I couldn't
seem to shake this one little silly
thing that I saw anyhow Knight f3 the
sloth defense is here c6 slob defense
and black says hey I am going to get my
bishop outside here where I can observe
the white pieces before he is boxed in
and a prisoner of his own pawns he
doesn't want to be stuck behind bars of
white pawns huh so if there's a drawback
with this Bishop move it's the queen bee
three response pinpointing b7 the now
weakened point so what does this mean
should I go with it Queen here or Knight
c3 Queen here there's queen bee six I
like this first let's do this in fact
I'm what I'm looking for is what am I
looking for me I could maybe run with
picking up this light square Bishop in
some lines with the night to h4 ideas
I'm gonna see about that though i don't
know i am still thinking about this move
okay and i think this is not a good idea
first and foremost because it gives up
the center and i could get that pond
back with tempo so here somebody had
already summarized it very well and they
threw it in they threw it down in the
twitch chat in equation form that person
being who in the twitch app
I did see it a little bit ago chest
starts chest start is the one that
referenced it he said tempo equals time
so I'm playing e4 with tempo with a gain
of time I'm not giving my opponent move
to now make where its advancing their
development they're having to do what
lose time they're moving a piece that
has already been developed they're not
making forward progress and in the
meantime this movement has also lost
time so there's a couple time issues
already on the black end so on the
subject of time if we're to still
continue in that direction what is a way
to put to use an advantage in time and
in this case space there is this
possibility for d5 and what then occurs
is the position blows up who is in a
better position for the position to blow
up here it's white because they have a
lead in development they have more
pieces out so castle and d5 are my
thoughts what's keeping me from doing
this right now maybe this Bishop
eventually coming out to give check or
the Queen I think if I really want to
get it in I could do it on my next turn
and that is what I'm going to look to do
d5 open lines open diagonals open ranks
blow the position open what about queen
bee three the bishop is unprotected
queen bee three Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes my bishop becomes an animal on
this dark square bit on this dark square
diagonal also my queen is pinpointing
this pun if there's a drawback it has to
do with maybe chop chop and then chop on
e4 I might be losing a pawn in some
variations maybe
okay queen bee three is my first thought
Bishop takes pawn takes I'm okay with
Bishop takes pawn there because I
grabbed this guy but I just try just say
you know what let's go d5 right now
right now yes I do say that and I say it
confidently open up the position when
you have a lead and development a good
thing to look into less than two minutes
where did that time go a lot of blabbing
early early on I guess with the tempo
stuff the tempo talk anyhow important
ideas even in these blitz games you'll
see them applied in what longer games
six our games possibly if you're
unfamiliar with chest that's how long
games could last even longer than six
hours that's about as long as that I've
ever played but seven hours more extreme
cases or what eight hours maybe anyhow
same principles apply now what what are
the candidate moves I'm ready to win
upon this is a serious threat now my
opponent is behind in development behind
with the time and facing threats that
don't really have convenient replies
like what do you do you assign a
babysitter to this e6 pawn or do you say
you know what I don't want to assign a
babysitter do them and I just going to
take and after chop-chop the e files
opened up and the king is not excited
about being on the same file as the rope
mm trouble it seems like trouble
wherever you turn for black right now
and it's because of these earlier time
time issues taking away from the center
allowing me to play e4 with tempo
grabbing this pawn pushing d5 now what
do you do kill the night chop-chop
chop-chop the positions opening up Queen
takes Queen there'd be an in-betweener
followed by another in between it may be
with check we could be seen something
like a pawn takes Knight with check
variation maybe is there something
better than capturing right away if
there is it's maybe this since this
diagonal has now been opened Queen check
would force night here or would it maybe
there's something it's my bishop let me
just recap sure about even okay ten
second difference between both clocks
here now what
okay 90 seconds to figure it all out 14
black I don't know about this what do
you do I'm not sure what to I don't know
what to suggest for the line here Lucas
the lion um I don't know okay chop-chop
and now this guy is ready to turn into
the big bad wolf right here the bishop
once played to a 3 says you will not
castle anytime soon no you won't okay I
do not in a position where I have or
where I feel I have the safer King I do
not want to trade Queens I could
consider taking right away or throwing
in a check i'm looking at forceful moves
first actually I really wasn't but I
should have been rookie one check night
blocks I could play Bishop e3 and give
this guy up chop him I think I get the
Queen at the end of it I should probably
do this this is probably best so let's
do it if its best let's do it if its
best why not check Bishop here setting
yourself up for real world of hurt if
you do that right here Bishop here maybe
this was not the best idea for me
actually what about check this is
working give a check followed by bishop
here TKO this is working it's a very
clean approach to this this position
right here I don't have to start there's
very little calculation that's what i
meant in that in this uh when i use the
word clean i was actually meaning very
little calculation involve ders I'm not
having to deal with
me being down maybe a piece for a move
or two and then trying to get it back
it's very very clean so first things
first let me take the night right now
and only then by default if you are not
already programmed as a chess player to
attack pinned pieces if you're if you're
thinking about already taking the night
don't do that think about attacking it
more attack the pinned pieces don't
capture the pinned pieces they're not
going anywhere they can't hurt you if
they can't move usually so this is a
problem there's no good solution and
there's no time remaining flight square
on the dark square last point I guess to
make before the clock is dead there it
is okay good game let's back up let's
hit the rewind button and make hopefully
an improvement or two or three let's
back up from your perspective what are
we have what do we have going on here
the bishop is out the night is out you
capture the pun you can't do it nope
nope nope nope nope I've seen this move
but it's not the correct moment to do it
where might there be a correct moment to
do such a move how about this how about
if where might you see that move played
you might see it played when white can't
respond with e for with tempo on the
bishop but I am able to play that right
now so it's not worthwhile to do this
this is not sometimes you'll see this
capture the acceptance of the Queens
gambit but it's going to be much more of
an inconvenience for white to eventually
recapture that pun in this case it's not
I play e4 boom hitting your Bishop I
recapture I just happen to be regaining
the material but what I what am I really
doing I'm just developing the bishop
comes back here we are I have it I have
a huge lead in development
I'm two moves away you are one two three
four five moves away it's a great great
loss of time and if you're struggling to
find something good in this position
it's because maybe there wasn't it's
because maybe it's the earlier decisions
the decision to give up the center like
this going all the way back to this move
will move our way out move for it's
important to hang on to this guy so what
might you want to consider I'm saying
not to do this so what should you maybe
do how about e6 something you eventually
did but you don't give up your center
point you don't give up d 5 you don't
give up the one pond that you have on
one of these four squares right here e
69 f 697 the bishop one of these two
squares maybe a queen bee 6 move in
response to a queen bee three move if we
if white takes the Queen you recapture
and then you would have play that would
actually be quite good for black anyhow
e 6 is my suggestion another actually
you might be wondering why not Knight f6
instead of e6 if Knight f6 there could
be this seat XD seat XD and then queen
bee three and the queen bee six replied
then is maybe a bit suspect because if I
if white does run for Queen takes Queen
the pond recapture or the resulting
queenside structure is double isolated
be pawns whereas if you play e6 right
now and after CD ed queen bee three
queen bee six Queen takes Queen takes
Queen it's a group of ponds and you know
two of the four are doubled but they're
at least together so there is a
difference between this e six and Knight
f6 move on this move for for black and I
think you should be going with e6 first
be in a position to recapture with your
epon should see takes d occur and then
move forward with your minor pieces
coming into play night out Bishop out
connect your Knights queen Knight to d7
get your butt castled and go from there
okay so anyhow some pointers to be
taking away without a doubt so